it's gonna be so easy and I'm gonna look
like an idiot you have a shot of whiskey
and two empty shot glasses can you make
a bridge between the empty glasses that
supports the shot of whiskey if you can
you get twenty bucks if you can you get
the shot of whiskey what in a previous
life I like to think I could have been
an architect basically what I'm trying
to figure out is how to make this taut
enough this is gonna go horribly wrong
let's do this so I have to make a bridge
I'm assuming there's some folding
involved I'm just gonna take you out of
the equation right now okay that's not
gonna work I'm gonna spill everywhere
[Music]
I can't hold it I can't I can't touch it
are you sure you're not leaving out some
tools like some toothpicks this is going
really well why do I always do this to
myself I come here and get frustrated
time and time again I wonder if it's
like some sort of V if I pay you this
$20 can I get a hint okay is there a
longer 20 is this a shorter 20 but if I
try to like really crinkle it up that
stills not gonna work but if I just rip
this 20 dollar bill in half oh my god
this is it no come on I can do this
where is a pep talk when I need it I
don't I want to know how to do I want to
do this so badly without you telling me
let's go back to square one no I give up
I give up I give up show me all right
take the $20 bill and start folding long
ways on alternating sides until the bill
resembles an accordion
rest the folded bill on top of the empty
glasses place the full shot of whiskey
in the middle collect your money are you
gonna fold it up I did that are you
kidding me I'm gonna like what come on
but like that's stupid
and I'm gonna sip this clink you know I
don't wanna do this oh my god I already
regret it all right it goes we got back
to work
[Music]
[Music]